you and I have a bunch of things to talk
about uh first of all I want to
compliment you in another way which is
you have uh a standup special which has
dropped like literally like two days ago
I think um okay now everyone's
correcting me with four oh great because
we would have had a lot of calls why did
you have to why did you guys have to
correct me on that you're looking at us
like am I right yeah yeah yeah just say
yeah sure close enough idiot that's all
I need you were wrong it's just wrong
with a sof don't do it here now don't do
it here now don't do it in front of Gary
please okay okay uh don't you mean Jerry
yeah born on born on third base uh is
your is your standup special and it's
hilarious now full disclosure I'm such a
fan that I had some involvement uh with
my and with my people in uh helping to
to bring this to reality but I'm I'm
saying this as someone who hates himself
um how could I'd be more than happy to
on it if I could uh it's really
really funny and beautifully done thank
you it's really nice and so I I'm I'm
congratulations well I had a lot of fun
touring it and the people liked it and I
and I shot it in Toronto where they're
just so nice and really love comedy and
and so oh my God Canada grateful Toronto
oh my gosh uh that's where I that's
where my ghost is going to go when it
roams the Earth uh doing bits it's going
to go up to Toronto
that tast and they're so nice they're
they're they're really smart and they
laugh and they're fun yeah and what's
wrong why are you looking at me like
that I just what a weird thing to say
your ghost is going to go to Toronto and
you're just going to do bits yeah I
don't want to go to heaven heaven sounds
boring okay you're just stuck in like
this Purgatory I want to go talk to
Ellen or Roosevelt on a cloud I want to
go up to Toronto and do bits and then go
get like go to a cool restaurant
afterward by definition be a bunch of
people who love your bits yeah no I
don't like that that that seems
patronizing I wouldn't like that but you
think I'm sorry just going back to this
you think you're going to go to Toronto
you're G to appear as a ghost and people
are just going to be like let's see what
bitsy has yes what's Gary if you were in
Toronto and you knew that I had passed
away in the last year or two and you
heard that my ghost was in Toronto and
he was doing bits somewhere wouldn't you
check him out I would check him out and
then I would also spend a lot of time
seeing Rush
yeah but no in this scenario they're
dead too but they're also playing no no
no this is my idea of Heaven Rush's Rush
is T Rush is touring and Conan is doing
standup associated with it and and we're
also spending time breaking down some of
the licks uh the guitar licks and things
like that and and also the the I love it
the drum solo this man gets me this is
yeah now sense Gary uh you are a fellow
Massachusetts masshole like myself
you're from pey Yes um and uh you know
you talk about this a lot in your
special and you've touched on it before
but it really does inform a lot of your
comment uh which is I think uh quite
beautiful but you grew up poor you grew
up this no other way to say yeah we were
broke Jewish people which people think
oh that's a thing and but really most of
us especially in that time of of in the
70s a lot of people were broke so yes a
lot half the Jews would be broke too
right everybody was yeah so and that was
that informed me it also it developed my
my personality in in terms of my my
resentment towards certain kids growing
up who had more than us and it didn't
have to be much it could be a an above
ground pool and I would be like oh look
at the look at the opulence with these
people they don't know what it is to
struggle and and and there and and
Christmas used to just blow me away
these kids were just get so much for
Christmas right and and I would get a
thing eight nights of a thing but some
of them were practical which you don't
want for holidays like what well give me
an example of a practical Hanukkah gift
I remember I everybody says socks but I
would get pajamas which I very rarely
wore right because it just that there's
it was either freezing cold in my house
which required an electric blanket which
I can't even believe those things were
legal at the time they were just fire
starters but also also could be
electrocut I just know this I just know
this in Massachusetts but every time a
house burned down yes in the in the 50s
60s or 70s it was you'd see firemen
walking away afterwards because I'd hang
out at these things and they'd
always as a true arsonist does but but
they'd always be like shaking their
heads going and you'd always read in the
paper that it was an electric blanket an
electric blanket or there would be a
fire chief holding up a melted
lightbrite yes yes and it would be
hopefully it would be the clown because
the clown face would melt into a frown
yeah because he was he was upset by this
as well the clown not just the fire tree
but yeah those were those were the two
biggest fire causes what could go wrong
if you took uh 19 mid 20th century
knowledge of electrical wiring and and
ran it through a bunch of cotton and
nylon like what could go wrong yeah and
and then you go to sleep and just crank
and crank this thing yeah so uh people
would just burst into flames uh but um
so yeah so you grow up uh in pey and and
what's interesting is you said that it's
it gave you a completely different
perspective than a lot of kids have when
when you grew up not having you grew up
not having stuff and so that you
knew uh just by roote what things cost
oh yes and and and you had that all down
which you said when you don't have money
you know all of this stuff yes yes
that's what always irritated me I
remember I had this neighbor who went to
a to a summer camp and I was interested
in it because he came back with a and
this is a phenomenon of Jewish summer
camps where these kids who were who were
kind of average Athletics and
attractiveness would go to summer camp
and they would walk taller when they
return because they they were uh sort of
uh they had C all the Gentile kids from
the group so it was just the Jews were
standing out and the only choice the
girls had or the boys had were were
other Jewish people so there was this
thing and they would be so confident and
they because they had made out with a
girl over the over the summer where they
weren't getting any make out sessions in
in in junior high or or seventh grade or
anything and then they would come back
in the fall and they had more confidence
and I envy this and I remember asking
the kid well how much does this thing
cost he says I don't know why would I
know how much things cost I said oh you
would ask for something and your parents
would tell you no we can't afford it and
then they would tell you how much
everything cost yes so you do have that
much everything yeah I remember I wanted
this robot called 2XL which was really
just a a an eight track player that they
had somehow it was a brilliant thing
where it would it would ask you
questions and and it was a trivia thing
and and you got informed and it was $
54.87 in in in toys A R Us where my my
mom worked at the mall and she couldn't
afford a babysitter so I would at 9
years old walk around the mall for 3
hours while she worked and then when the
boss left I could go in there and hang
out at the at the stationary store but I
would walk around hang around at Toys R
R Us and at Sears you could play the
Atari for a while and then the orange
julius kids would give me free Julie
ey I love that you did the plural of
Julius that makes me so happy happy this
sounds like heaven it was it was
incredible you ever have fried
octopie with your Julie
ey so I was like the the mall mascot
basically and I would I would hang out
at the Toys R Us and and there was this
robot called 2XL and I knew it was 5487
and I would I would every year I would
ask for it and then I would Al but I
also would ask people if I could borrow
$548 which so specific but I hadn't
worked out the fact that it would
probably be 5% tax and and also the
parents would always say $55 but kids
would always know that there was 54.87
that was a big kid thing so I I think
did you ever get it I did get it my mom
there was a neighbor who who got it and
outgrew it uh several years later and my
mom bought it used from from them and
and gave it to me for my birthday and
and it worked 100% that it just the box
was damaged cuz cuz it had been
opened I remember at Christmas as being
perilous meaning you something great
could happen but also if you're one of
six wow you can get lost in the show
like yeah and Santa's busy because he's
a he's working at the microbiology
lab
and and sometimes Santa has a short
F and anyway I remember once we had this
tradition where we're asleep and Santa
would put the gifts they weren't WRA but
they would just each one each one of the
kids in the family had a uh has a piece
of furniture in the living room this
where my parents still live mind you wow
in Brooklyn mass and there's a different
piece of furniture and Luke's toys would
go on a chair and most people had a
chair and then be mine just arbitrarily
became there's this long white couch now
think about it everything looks tiny and
insignificant on a long white couch and
Santa is busy and there's a lot to do so
there were years where Santa's like okay
I got Neil covered I got Luke I got Jane
I got got Justin we got and then he's
down there and he's throwing stuff
around he's like I got to get back to
the lab I think that germ got out and
then you know I've been working on
something called covid I hope
it's but anyway that was my dad
anyway um what's his name uh Thomas okay
and so he would be uh I there was one
Christmas where I think he was throwing
everything around and then he got to the
giant white couch and there was some
socks and there wasn't much so never
forget that that was the year he got a
tobogan like for everyone to share but I
come running downstairs and I see this
giant tobogan filling out the couch and
I'm like I got a
tobogan this is insane and I never
forget my dad went ah
interesting Santa told me on his way out
that it's actually for everyone and I
went huh but it's like the one thing
that's on my couch and he went Santa
said you kind of get to be in charge of
it but it's for everyone and I'm like
first of all you're having a legal
conversation with Santa about ownership
and then how are you in charge of a
tobogan I get to decide who sits
where but that but hey I got over it I'm
60 and bitching about it on a
podcast the socialism of 1970s massachus
my God and I still to this day when I go
home and that white couch is still there
really and I'm I'll still look at it and
I'll be like
tobogan there was a tobogan and then
like some posits and some socks oh my
God and an electric blanket and then you
know like what kind of and anyway enough
about me I'm just saying we all suffer I
remember one year I did get a bunch of
Dungeons and Dragons books and you talk
about this you talk about this package
books but unfortunately it came with all
these Dice and the maps and everything
like that but it didn't come with any
any
friends and that is the the greatest
oversight of the of the
TSR company was that yeah kids who are
into this stuff are lonely